[Music]
okay uh hello everybody uh it's me Josh
again and today we're going to be
talking about the must win tournament
situation so it's really common uh
situation where especially with the
black pieces and indeed all the games
we're gonna be looking at today are from
the black side it's a really common
situation that people don't know what to
do if they really badly need a win and
their opponent is not so accommodating
and today today we're going to be
talking about some of the mindset and uh
approach that you're going to be using
when you're in a must win situation so
uh the must win situation can come about
for a ton of different reasons the one
that for most people is the most
pertinent and the most important is if
you're playing for either some sort of
Prize or for a international Master arm
or Grand Master Norm then in that case
it's definitely really important if you
need one point for your Norm then
sometimes a draw can feel the same as a
loss and other times it's not as serious
and it's just because you want to
preserve rating points playing in some
liberated player or something like this
so the first example is actually in the
ladder case but the future ones will be
in the more important situation
so the first game we have here I'm
playing Black against uh nikhail Kumar
so this was from the Philadelphia
International of 2021.
so in this case I'm playing Black
against someone who's about 2300 feet a
so not so bad but as we can see from the
opening white is has elected not to play
in the most ambitious way possible
so after this should be five check I've
never really thought about this move for
very long so very quickly I determined
that I do not want to play Bishop D7
because after Bishop D3 my move B6 it
looks a little bit silly in my Bishop on
D7 is not doing a whole lot here so
after Knight D7 I wasn't really too sure
what was White's idea since the bishop
on B5 seems a little bit strange in this
case but I very quickly found another
Knight E5
um
so why does now threatening Knight C6
which would be very uncomfortable for
black as a result of the bishop and the
queen being sort of forked but after A6
so in this case Knight C6 is no longer
very desirable for white
as the uh as the resulting position
would not be terribly dangerous for
black even though the King has been
forced to move probably even more
accurate to take the bishop first and
after Knight takes C8 I'd probably even
take on C with a queen and my Pawn
structure on the queen side is very
imbalanced and I'd be very happy to play
this position onward
um but after Bishop takes desang Bishop
takes D7 so at first I thought that
white was going to go for some sort of
attacking plan with G4 which is totally
fine
um but after castling I'm not really
afraid of being checkmated with uh with
white missing the light Square bishop or
anything like that so it wasn't really
overly scared of anything but then after
Knight takes D7 I realized pretty
quickly what sort of game we were going
to get white is uh pretty making it
pretty clear that white wants to trade a
lot of pieces and therefore I hope to
reach some Josh end game
so of course from a chess perspective
there's nothing particularly wrong with
this strategy since at the end of the
day everything is going to be equal but
it's definitely not something you are
really enthusiastic to play against when
you have the black pieces
so our first challenge here comes after
the move C4 so basically white is
announcing that white wishes to take on
D5 and there black can choose between
recapturing with the e-pawn which
results in a what we call the hanging
pons pawns on D5 and C5 that are not
supported by any neighbors
or taking on D5 with the piece and
creating an isolated Pawn on C5 so
so here this is a already a source of a
pretty tough decision for black so in
this case
um black needs to decide what pawn
structure to go for and what move to
play since uh the most obvious move for
black that would try to maintain an
imbalance D4
would actually in fact just simply drop
a pawn to takes takes at Knight F3 as E5
is not possible in this position
so after C4 I decided that if I wanted
to try to win the game I probably do not
want to take with a pawn so the reason I
made this decision is because after
something like Rook C8 takes takes I
figured that it'd be very difficult for
me to make any further progress in this
position not 100 sure what my plan is
going to be white probably will play
something like Rook C1 and it's not the
end of the world or anything but it's
very hard for me to make progress in C4
always makes my Pawn take C4
and D4 wise again met by Knight C4 as
well severely weaken the C4 Square
so I decided uh fairly quickly that I
want to take with the piece somehow
um
but probably not with the Knight since
uh but we can just input some fairly
roof like Rook d8 takes Knight takes
Knight C4 and the white position is
super solid here
so what I had realized was that if I
want to maintain some form of imbalance
and indeed try to win the game the best
way for me to do that would be by
beginning with Queen takes D5 so in that
case
the only way to make an active plan
after Queen takes D5 uh well Queen takes
D5 is very ugly move because we are
indeed leaving ourselves with two
isolated pawns on C5 and A6 but so what
I decided to do was to start with the
move A5 so that after C takes D5 Queen
takes D5 which does not have to happen
right away but eventually after it takes
in Queen takes D5 I will have the plan
of A4 to soften up the B3 Pawn hey Josh
I need to just adjust this real quick oh
yes
um better now oh yeah okay all right so
after A5 Rook C1 Rook fd8 so now white
decided to finally relieve the tension
with C takes D5 by the way it's very
important this move work fd8 since the
immediate A4 would allow um
would allow some pretty unfortunate
tactics based on the weak Z5 Pawn for
example e takes D5 in this position
would already be losing after Bishop
takes and 94.
so I decided to start with Rook FDA just
to try to get white to clarify the
situation in the center also white needs
to be really careful about the move d4
now being possible as the pawn is free
to advance forward so might precise they
finally relieve the tension here with C
takes T5 and queen takes D5
so here we've reached our
Zone our so-called sort of optimal
position so after Queen takes D5 uh why
why it's Knight is under attack and the
most natural way to resolve this problem
is to play Knight C4
and so what I thought about this
position was that if white wishes to
was that I as black do not want to trade
Queens since I really want to win and I
don't want to enter an end game if
that's possible
so I do not particularly want to trade
Queens but if the circumstances arise
then in the right situation it may be
profitable trade Queens so in this
position I want to move my queen
somewhere since I don't want to allow
white to Simply take on D5 or anything
like this
and most likely we'll have to move my
queen along the A8 to H1 diagonal and
indeed that is what happened after Queen
B7 it's also possible to start with A4
and indeed this my neck should be better
but more or less I figured that uh I'm
probably just not going to win here it
seems very difficult to make any
progress the with such a few minor
pieces on the board I think the uh B3
Pawn is not going to become a serious
issue and indeed this end game is
extremely close to drawn so even though
the engine might tell you that this is
the best move
it goes to show that this is not really
relevant from a practical standpoint and
does not help black to achieve his goal
so after Knight C4 Queen B7 so I'd
anticipated that in this position it's
possible for white to play the Queen F3
and insist on a trade of Queens however
the doubling of the f-pawns is very
unfortunate for white and indeed is not
positionally desirable so that's why I
felt comfortable with trading Queens in
this instance I believe that white
should probably play a move like Queen
C2 or queen E2
um
either is probably fine and just try to
maintain some tension given that the
pawn structure is pretty similar most
likely black would play A4 and after
Pawn takes A4 black would eventually
regain this pawn and you'd have another
equal position but this one hopefully
with a little bit more open-ended
but after Queen F3 Queen takes F3 upon
takes F3
um I don't want white to take an F6 as
the black Bishop will end up being worse
than the white knight in that case so
Knight D5
and in this particular position
um white can actually obtain an
advantage according to the computer by
playing a move that is really insane I
definitely would not have been very
scared of the move A4
this position is roughly equal but the
weakness of the C5 Pawn is more
important than the B3 Pawn so perhaps
the position is slightly preferable for
white but again there are remain
imbalances here and this is really
important when you're trying to make
sure that you win the game
so uh I I don't think that this would
have been terribly frightening and
additionally this is very difficult to
understand uh that since A4 is not
generally speaking a desirable move for
white in this sort of Pawn structure so
for that reason I think Queen F3 is a
pretty poor choice because as we'll see
in the game if white pursues normally
then black is the one who has the
initiative
so in this position we run into another
sort of Crossroads so we've already
achieved our main plan of playing A4
which is definitely a concession from
White so we've already made some
improvement in our position relative to
White's position
so the next thing to do is to uh
figure out some sort of plan so
in this position unfortunately there's
not really so much to do on the queen
side anymore the queen side has been
largely liquidated and the A3 Pawn is
going to be very secure pretty much no
matter what we do
so I decided to make some King side
expansion in this case so I started off
with the move F6 the move F6 has
multiple purposes the first idea is with
King F7
and the second idea we'll see executed
shortly after Rook D2 with the new G5
so G5 is a pretty interesting move
because the move first of all succeeds
in severely restricting the white king
side so first of all move F4 it's
obviously not possible now because black
one assembly capture on F4 and if white
one to play E4 then the move G5 helps to
support a knight coming to F4 so after
G5 it turns out that white is not really
able to do too much about this move and
black is free to expand on the king side
so I decided that H5 was a good move to
have included at this point I'm not yet
sure if I actually want to play G4 at
any point but it seems fairly likely and
I don't have to make that just a
decision until much later
so the game white played Knight D2 uh
maybe looking for some sort of 94
business try and Target that C5 Pawn
which can potentially become weak in the
future
so Rook B8
The Rook no longer serves any particular
purpose on the D file so it's perfectly
fine to move it away
Rook B1 and the next few moves are are
Show an example of what Jeremy sulman
called cat and mouse in his book on
um in his book on end games so in this
case the specific moves for black do not
particularly matter the important things
that black is the person who has the
initiative in this position and this
will not change over time there's
nothing white can really do to uh to
remove this initiative so it's perfectly
fine to just play Slowly with moves like
Rook V6 and Rook A8 just slowly trying
to improve the position again very
important to not make any trades if it
does if it is at all possible
um so in this case uh White is
definitely the person feeling the
pressure although at the same time it's
not that white has it's not like white
has done anything super terribly wrong
so the best play White should still be
able to equalize
in this case I decided to start with G4
King G2 and King F7
so in this particular position uh White
is already facing a pretty tough
situation
um although like again black doesn't
really have any super concrete threats
or anything like that
um
uh it's very difficult for white to come
up with a constructive plan and indeed
the situation is pretty difficult
um what's up bro how are you I'm good
Pepe hands finding the urge not to trade
yeah exactly that's that's basically
what I'm trying to do here
um although like obviously I'm not
stupid I know that like if I have the
the black pieces and white plays
perfectly then there's not really too
much you can do at the end of the day
but at the same time I want to make this
as difficult for the opponent as
possible and again not trading is a big
part of this
um
so after King F7 so what white should do
here is that white should try to
simplify the position as much as
possible by taking on G4 and then
preparing the move H3 by way of Rook H1
and the truth is that black still
definitely has a more pleasant position
here but at the end of the day with
proper defense white should be able to
more or less equalize
um you you certainly could play
something like Rook G8
um
yeah yeah
um I think the I think the main problem
is that at the end of the day you won't
be able to stop the exchange of ponds in
the in the end
um
yeah yeah you certainly can there's
nothing particularly wrong with it uh it
doesn't really change the character of
the position much
um I think with black generally you want
to trade the pawns uh you want to trade
as few pawns as possible since um so
it's generally when you have the
advantage and end games less pawns means
uh greater likelihood of a drawn
resulting end game so probably I I would
just simply take on G4 but this is also
possible and the position here is still
preferable for black as the white Kings
a little bit of a weird position so
again also totally fine
um
yeah so that's what white should do but
white decided to play F4 in the game
which is a pretty serious mistake so and
again we can see how uh by putting
pressure on white we were able to create
a situation where the right move and
wrong move are not so obvious for
example F4 being a mistake is already a
bit of an unorthodox situation since it
is very difficult to imagine how black
it's going to break through that King
side formation
so I decided to start with Rook B8
Knight C4 Rook B3 again uh there's not
really too much being achieved by the
maneuvering of the Rooks on the B file
but potentially but as white uh the
defending side it's important that white
needs to be worried about things like
Rook D3 or maybe a doubling on the third
Rank and the pressure on E3 can
potentially be useful in the case of
future H4 and G3
so after Rook A1
now I decided it was time to advance
with H4
so this is why it's pretty much last
chance to uh
to try to simplify the game and white
pretty much needs to play H3 in this
position it was not overly worried about
this in the game because I figured I
could play G3 which would severely
undermine that E3 Pawn for example after
F takes G3 it's possible to even take on
E3 with a rook seems very attractive
with the pressure on the third Rank and
Knight takes E3 would result in a knight
Fork so uh so yeah that's all well and
good and I also thought that GTX H3 was
pretty strong since King takes H3 Knight
takes F4 using the aforementioned third
rank pin to my advantage the truth is
that why you should play King H2 and
apparently this is more or less
tolerable for white but again not
definitely not an easy decision from
White at all
yeah yeah chessler Knight takes F4 would
be would be pretty good here
um but the the problem is that white is
not going to take an H3 and so after
King H2 the H pawns on the H file are
actually not particularly helpful to me
but after H4 white played Bishop C1 and
now we have an opportunity to see why F4
is such a bad move it's because by
placing all the king side pawns on the
dark squares white has effectively made
it so that any end game involving a
trait of Rooks is going to be extremely
unpleasant
so after H3 check King F1 and F5 black
is a huge Advantage here and indeed the
rest of the game is not so
um
challenging
I think that uh that my opponent had
already decided that uh
that the way to meet F5 was by using
this Taft code trig with Knight C6 so
the idea here is that white eventually
wishes to take an E7 and grab the C5
Pawn and Rook B5 would not be sufficient
thanks to A4 and putting pressure on The
Rook but unfortunately for white the
tactics do not work which is relatively
a common situation where if you're if
you have the worst position the tactics
are not going to work and so so because
the Knight on V8 is hanging white does
not currently have time to take on C5
but Knight A6 does seem to collect the
pawn
um but there's a very nice trick here
available to Black with Rook B1 and
Knight takes C5 Bishop B2 so because of
the positioning of the Knight on C5 Rook
takes V2 Rook C1 check is not viable
since the Knight will be hanging at the
end
and Knight D3 has played in the game
drops the a pawn after which the win is
a matter of technique
um even here it's not particularly
obvious how to break through but um
but the H2 Pawn being so weak means that
white is never going to be able to move
the bishop on C1 and therefore black
should be able to just slowly improve
the position here after Bishop D6 the
truth is that white is actually also
fairly close to zuk Swan but something
like King D7 next would probably be the
plan
the Knight B2
Knight B2 is fight intending some sort
of Knight C4
um
and I decided to try to jump into C3
with my knight obvious not possible
right away so Bishop B4 it is and 91
very sad move but no other way to
prevent Knight C3 which is very
important
um because if the Knight were to land on
e4 and Y would be facing pressure on F2
as well
so in this case I decided to Simply make
a waiting move with Brooke A1 the
specific moves here are not terribly
important but the move Rook A1 was
played to sort of avoid The Rook being
trapped on B2
by Bishop B2
and uh light played Bishop B2 hoping to
expel The Rook from the white camp and
the again black remains with a great
position virtually no matter what
happens but Bishop B2 does happen to
drop a pretty funny tactic in the
position perhaps somebody in twitch chat
or Tim in the audience would like to uh
point out the way that black should play
huh
any ideas Tim
oh yes what's your suggestion
sorry what'd you say
yeah so we've got a couple of okay twos
in the chat um Rook A2 is fine but uh
it's not nearly as decisive as the movie
suggested by uh Garrett Lee uh that
being G3 so after G3 so white has a
couple of options here the first one to
check is obviously capturing the free
rook on A1 and after Bishop takes A1 it
turns out the white pieces are not
effectively placed to counter the H Pawn
and black assembly gonna promote an H1
and with the new Queen the game will be
over
F takes G3 is a little bit trickier to
refute but the key here lies in the
bizarre constellation of pieces here and
indeed after Rook takes D1 white is
going to lose here since after black
trades the Knight for The Rook
um the remaining pawns as we pointed out
before remain all on the dark squares
and indeed black has several ways to win
the game here uh I think the funniest
one is probably Bishop E1 since on no
matter what moves white plays Black's
going to capture the pawn on G3 and
force a promotion
so in the game white played H takes G3
which is probably the most uh the most
effective defense so it looks like black
is going to be able to push through that
H2 that H Pawn
um because Bishop takes A1 H1 Queen is
pretty effective
um but unfortunately after H2 white does
not have to be so cooperative and
because there is only a single H Pawn on
the H file white is able to go for Rook
C8 and then Rook h8 winning the H2 pawn
and uh seems very unlikely that black is
going to win the game here
but the key is that again because
White's pieces are placed so poorly it's
perfectly possible to just simply
prevent Rook CA with move King D7 and
after Bishop takes A1 H2 there is no way
to prevent the pawn from reaching its uh
ending Place Knight C3 H1 and the game
ends with a pretty funny uh uh maneuver
here so uh White word to play King G2
then The Rook drops off and queen E4
would pick up the Knight on B4 with of
course the completely winning position
and rookie 2 Queen H1 is one of the
better checkmates I've seen in my time
so
um yeah basically the thing to take away
from this game is that even if you're in
a must win situation that doesn't
necessarily mean you have to go crazy or
do any uh sort of like uh unsound attack
or anything like this it's perfectly
fine to just create some just try to
create some positional advantages and
then capitalize on them by playing
slowly and uh just being careful and
eliminating the losing chances you're
able to increase the pressure on your
opponent we're going to be looking at a
couple more examples of this going
forward
so the next game I want to look at is
actually a game that is very important
to me so this was in the last round of
the Charlotte uh
July Grand Master Norm tournament and so
in this case I actually started out the
tournament really well on round one I
had beat magesh panchonathon a grand
master with black and uh
and I had myself with a five and a half
out of eight at the end of the day so
pretty good but if you have ever been to
or heard of the round robin Norm
tournaments in Charlotte you would know
that they generally want you to have six
and a half so uh this game where I was
playing Black against the very strong FM
gory Shankar
um
ended up being the deciding game for my
second Grand Master Norm which is a
really important deal for anyone who
wants to become a grand master since you
need three of them and they're pretty
hard to get
so before the game I noticed that gory
mostly plays some uh
some sort of uh one Knight of three or
English type of situation and in both
cases I had movies prepared I had lines
prepared that would lead to some sort of
imbalanced position
so after nine of three we have D5 G3 and
Bishop G4 Bishop G2 so everything here
is fairly normal so far in this case the
most common move I believe is the move
Knight D7 but generally speaking I find
that this Pawn structure is a little bit
undesirable for black since after white
plays E4 I'm never really quite sure
what black is going to be playing for
and
um and many of the key lines here will
involve a lot of Peace trades although
of course it ends up being fine for
black but again peace trades are not
exactly what I want to do when I'm in a
must-win situation
so in the game I decided to go for C6
which shows an altogether different plan
against the early C4 which you're about
to see in action so after it's C4 E6 C
takes D5
so the idea for black that I wanted to
go for in the game was to play with the
pawn structure with C takes D5 the
reason for this is because the bishop
Bing on G2 makes it so that despite the
asymmetrical Pawn structure sorry
despite the symmetrical Pawn structure
the white Bishop being on G2 will result
in Black having winning chances since
the bishop is very ineffective here
unfortunately the immediate C takes D5
would simply lose the game in one move
to Queen A4 forking the king and working
the
forking the king and Bishop here
so it's very important for black to
begin with Bishop takes F3 and so if you
actually look at some Theory you'll
notice that in this position black
should not play 97 black should play
something like Knight F6 and always wait
for C takes D5 before capturing on F3
the reason for this is because in the
resulting Pawn structure black wishes to
place the B8 Knight on C6 and not D7 so
this is why black avoids playing Knight
D7 very early
so in the game we have C takes D5 Bishop
takes F3 she takes F3 cd5 he has those
and Knight F6 so uh I've chosen this
line for several reasons number one I
simply think it's a very good line and
number two it's actually quite difficult
to determine what white should play here
if you are looking at this position for
the first time so white has great
flexibility in the position but only one
of White's plans has really any sort of
uh weight behind it
so and I also know that gory is a player
who is generally speaking quite prone to
time pressure so my guess was that he
would probably spend a lot of time
thinking about this decision here
so after Knight F6 uh he chose the wrong
plan with B3 which is a very innocuous
move and goes to show how good
preparation can be very useful
um how like B3 is a very unobvious
mistake but turns out to be relatively
ineffective the generally speaking the
best way for white to play will be
playing D4 trying to transpose into some
exchange slop of course this is a very
good version for black as the light
Square Bishop is considered a problem
piece in the exchange love and a white
slight screw Bishop is very poor so
white generally has to play E3 at some
point and try to reroute the bishop of
course I would not have been
particularly afraid here I was perfectly
comfortable playing for a win from this
sort of position
um it's game after B3 Knight C6 Bishop
B2 Bishop D6
the bishop on B2 does not combine very
well with D4 so gory correctly plays D3
the problem is that this light Square
Bishop on F3 uh does not really have
much of a future being running into all
of these pawns so it's possible for
white to play E4 at some stage but
generally speaking is going to be very
difficult to achieve
in this position had I uh
had I been a little bit more courageous
I might have gone for H5 which I didn't
really seriously consider in the game
because I believed I had a perfectly
acceptable position anyway
after castles Knight C3
um
we have a position where uh personally I
felt very good about where the game was
at the white minor pieces are not doing
very much so definitely it's the
position seems to be easier to for black
to play in my opinion so I started off
with the bricks d8 uh nothing really
controversial here Rook occupying the
open file and such
Knight B5 so Knight on C3 is not really
achieving much here being that D5 is so
well protected so gory decides to
reroute it to a D4 Square
at the same time the night's not so
devastating on D4 or anything like this
so just Queen A5
um
so as black here I'm really strongly
thinking about a move like Bishop A3 to
try to eliminate dark Square Bishops so
I can play against this guy in the end
game so gory decides to preclude that
possibility with move like A3
but now A3 happens to soften up the B3
Pawn so I decide to continue the
pressure with the move Queen B6
so again these specific moves are not
really so important the general approach
and how the pawn structure is being
handled the more important
um
as we can see here just because we have
this sort of symmetry does not mean that
there's no opportunity to do anything
especially given that black is the one
with the better piece placement
so after Queen B6 of course the d49 is
under pressure so gory decides to play
E3 which is probably a move that white
needs to make anyway seeing as that E4
is pretty much entirely unfeasible at
any point
so E3
and so now I want to improve our worst
place pieces it's not an F6 in
particular it doesn't really have
anywhere to go right now so 97 it is
there many potential options here maybe
Knight C5 or Knight E5 to pressure that
d-pawn
and more importantly this is the move 97
gives black the opportunity to continue
with Bishop F6 which is very desirable
as again we want to trade off the dark
Square Bishops here
so B4 Bishop F6 takes takes and so if
white was was in time to trade the
Bishops and then erect this sort of dark
Square Pawn chain with D4 and that might
be very appealing but the problem is
that white is not in time to challenge
the C file if this is being done and
therefore black would still have an
advantage here
so in the game gory decides to play D4
and lock up that diagonal to try to keep
a couple more pieces on the board
but this is something that I'm very
satisfied with as that dark screw Bishop
is now looks like the Saturn of White's
two Bishops being blocked in by seven
pawns present on dark squares so Rook
fc8
and of course I'm very happy to
emphasize my control of the C file and
invade through that second rank
so at first it appears that white might
be able to play something like Rook C1
trying to challenge that file but this
will not hold for very long after take
stakes and queen C6 uh
sorry what'd you say
oh okay I understand
yes yes yes yeah in this position Roxy
one is is pretty clever as the bishop
cannot be captured on account of C8
being hanging but unfortunately for
white after Rook takes C1 and queen C6
White's not gonna be able to prevent the
black queen from navigating through C3
or C2 again resulting in a great
position for black
um Bishop C1 is another way for uh to
try to expel the pieces but in the long
run it will not prevent black from
having an excellent chance
a very imbalanced position with
excellent chances for counter play for
example this maneuver Knight V6 Knight
C4 in the future is going to be very
uncomfortable for white as a consequence
of white white what white has done with
the pawn structure early on
so the game white played Rook B1 which
is slightly more passive but is another
way of preparing Bishop D3
and in this position so what's the next
plan I've succeeded in taking it over
the C file but that's not the end of the
story so I have one piece here that's
not really doing anything well okay I
suppose my Bishop on F6 is not so hot
here but nothing I can really do about
it in this particular position it's much
more pertinent to improve that night on
D7 so Queen D6 prepares the move Knight
B6 and an invasion of the C4 Square
which is very weak here so Bishop D3
Rook C7
um
yeah A5 is possible
um there's nothing particularly wrong
with it just um white gets to take the
pawn and because of the queen is hanging
we're not able to take the bishop and so
here White's able to expel the Rooks
uh how
uh here
but Queen V3 is possible Right
yeah if anything our Rook might actually
be in some trouble yeah it might be a
little bit hard to get out
um but yeah if A5 is definitely a really
important idea for black in this
position
um just to sort of break through but not
in this specific case because right now
white does have the bishop pair and The
Rook uh so we don't want to be opening
up the position too much and that Rook
on B1 is going to be uh is going to be a
little bit Unleashed after the move A5
does that make sense
all right great
yeah I mean I'm sure the position is is
still good for black after um A5 takes
takes Bishop D3 uh probably you should
just Retreat The Rook or something and
probably black is still better here but
um I believe that the that the queen
side staying closed for now is desirable
um a really good uh tip to take away by
the way uh everybody is that um if you
feel that your position is very nice and
very comfortable you should always
strongly you should you should generally
speaking you should be strongly averse
to the idea of transforming the pawn
structure greatly
um even if this this benefits you you
should always be careful that uh that
you're not just much better in the
original position since generally
speaking if your position is already
Pleasant then you should try to just
keep going with that if it ain't broke
don't fix it or something like that
um
so after Rook Beyond Queen D6 so the
closed position is working out very well
for me I have perfect control of the
only open file and just by improving my
knight through B6 and C4 I'm going to
reach a great position so Bishop D3
pretty much necessary to expel that very
annoying Rook from C2
Rook C7 Queen E2 so now in this case why
does preparing Rook fc1 to challenge the
C file which is perfectly fine with me
and indeed this is what how the game
continued Knight on C4 is super strong
here and not really too much white can
do in order to remove it
so Knight C4
um
so white has a choice here between
either taking on C4 or simply waiting
perhaps the option of waiting is better
but I don't I'm not particularly afraid
here I would continue to prove my
position G6 is a pretty good way to do
so since uh it's very unlikely why it's
gonna be able to use my dark squares in
the king side and creating loft is
always a good idea
um
and after Bishop takes C4 which was
happy to the game Rook takes C4 so
there's actually another really
important choice here to be made whether
to take on C4 with the Rook or with the
pawn
so taking with the pawn is very tempting
because the protected pass Pawn on C4 is
likely to be strong but after Bishop C3
I found that the position would be a
little bit hard to break through and
what's more important is that I just
felt that White's moves from here would
become fairly obvious whereas after Rook
takes C4 white still needs to make a lot
of choices
so for example after the move Rook C1
now I thought Queen C6 looked a little
bit more appealing since after Rook
takes C4 do you take C4 without the
Rooks I think white will find it a
little bit harder to hold this pawn and
after B5 I'm going to press this
position forever
so it felt pretty good about that
and indeed in the game uh White decided
to prepare for a queen C6 in another way
with the move Rook D1 green C6 and Rook
D2 so as we can see here on materials
even uh Pawn structure remains more or
less symmetrical but white has a severe
disadvantage here so
um the main problem for white is that
the bishop on B2 is extremely weak and
in association with it those Queen side
pawns are very poor
so here I decided that my Bishop on F6
is no longer particularly doing much
here remember that we moved it here
earlier just to induce the move d4
so I decided to improve it with Bishop
d8 so at first this particular choice of
square seems a bit strange but remember
that uh it's very hard for me to attack
these pawns as it is so I would really
like to play the move A5 in order to
soften that up and having support of
that score with my Bishop is a very
ideal
so Queen D3 and here there's no
particular need to hurry so G6 Perfectly
Natural here with black
um so A5 here is perfectly possible
um
yeah yeah I mean uh black it has a great
Advantage virtually no matter what you
play at this point the specific moves
are not so important but again I want to
make it so that the position that is
already going very well for me continues
going very well and
um
and I can improve my position a lot
because thing is here that white cannot
prevent me from playing A5 in the long
run so I might as well improve my
position to the maximum first before
doing that so uh as you can see I do
play A5 pretty soon but uh under much
hostage
yeah yeah I mean you'll see something
very similar ends up happening in the
game actually
Theory support for
you know
I mean I would never pretend that
trade if I was
if you played A4
well I mean like for example if I like
for example if I put bishop d8 and white
makes a move like King G2 then like for
example this would not be possible for
white because Rook C2 wins a piece
um so like so first of all it does make
A5 a lot stronger and secondly white
can't do anything about it like white
count prevented you from playing A5
white cannot change the configuration
and pieces on the queen side much very
much right so then I don't have anything
to lose from just playing like G6 and
improving my king a bit before playing
A5 does that make sense because
I did not see efficiency to the end it
brought to you C2 at the end yeah yeah I
mean again it's it's not even like super
necessary it's just that like there's no
reason to uh open up the position and
make it a little bit easier to play for
white immediately rather than uh just
holding the position still because in
this position white cannot make moves
white cannot like make moves that
appreciatively make progress as you'll
see in the game I mean my opponent's a
pretty strong FM pretty close to 2400
veto and he decided that Queen D3 and
rookie 2 was the best way to improve the
position because there is no way to
improve the position available does that
make sense yeah I was just sending you
through um
58 and then
pretty one
and then you're he's holding you off and
sliding the data
um yeah yeah I mean it's certainly
possible
sure
yeah
four hangs the B Pawn Yeah
I was thinking they should be a queen E1
so I play is A5
uh well sure but I have no particular
reason to play five right away right I
might as well just this is a useful move
it creates left right so I'll just play
G6 first I don't think so
this is
wait I don't know just like uh do you
have like a further question or
okay yeah I mean the thing is like white
doesn't really have any active plan so
like before making any sort of
breakthrough it's just like really
generally useful to just like make these
little improving moves like uh I mean as
we said before this bishop is not
particularly useful in F6
um and um and like I want to make love
to my king at some point so G6 is useful
and from here after Rook E2 so A5 in
this position is fine but not
immediately necessary so I started with
Queen B5 in the game uh just creating a
cheeky little thread of Rook C1 as well
as Rook takes B4 making use of this
diagonal so White Queen is forced to
move away with Queen D1
and after A5 Pawn takes A5 Bishop takes
A5 we can see that the black Bishop has
entered the game rather than being stuck
on F6 so after King G2 again we have
another case where not really anything
for white to do so why not let's start
with King f8
King f8 H4 King E8 looks a little bit
strange to do this and allow white so
much time on the king side but in many
key lines you will notice that being
able to play King D7 to seal off the C
file for white can be particularly
useful so I just started decided to
start with move Rook C6
so let's move Rook C6 allows potential
for Queen C4 and then later perhaps Rook
B6 or something like this many
possibilities but the Rook is no longer
doing too much on C4
and the game white continue with A4 to
try to free the position a little bit
but after Queen before takes takes
um
white is pretty much only left with the
idea Bishop A1 to try to occupy the B
file with the Rook
but after Queen C4 turns out that Rook
P2 is not so strong for a
reason
um
I think probably Queen C1 is the move
yeah I think Queen C1 is pretty strong
there since before Exchange in Queens is
very good for black
so when white continues with Bishop B2
just trying to prevent that exchange of
Queens
and now uh so white wishes to place the
bishop on A3 and I decided to prevent
that with Bishop B4 so big component of
how to play in this sort of position is
to prevent White's counter play as much
as possible so Bishop B4 well white
should do in this position is Play
Bishop A1 back and of course this is
very much not what white should be
really excited about playing so instead
white decided to make a mistake by
trying to quote unquote improve the
position with F3 intending E4
to Bishop D6 E4 Rook A6 so the a pawn is
very weak so white concocted this E4
takes D5 plan to get my Queen off it but
unfortunately the cost is a little bit
too great uh the white king remains
extremely weak on G2 and The Black Queen
on D5 is absolutely dominating the
position Blockheads the D4 Pawn puts
pressure on the king and looks at the
queen side as well
so after Bishop C1 uh now funnily enough
the correct Square for the black Rook
where it puts the most pressure on all
of White's targets is again C4 so Rook
returns to C4
and uh so if white wants to trade the
Bishops with Bishop F4 which would be
positionally desirable for white
unfortunately in this case the cost is a
little bit high as I have to Rook C4
white will be dropping upon very soon in
the near future
so Gary decides to go for a bishop E3 at
this point in extreme time trouble just
trying to hold everything together
Rook C3 so this move is a little bit
better than Rook C4 as D4 is now
protected and I'm instead actually
eyeing the F3 Pawn as well as looking at
Rook A3 to get behind this A4 Pawn
we need to Rook A3 so all these little
weaknesses are pretty soon going to be
serious problems for White Queen C2 and
now we can see another great point about
playing the move King earlier with King
D7 and black has a winning position here
since white can't really achieve any
counter play and the weaknesses in
White's position all remain very
apparent
king of two
and again in this in this position the
particular moves are no longer super
important but Rook A1 is quite nice so
preparing some sort of Rook H1 swing
over and Rook H2 to loosen up that F3
Pawn
King G2 holds H1 again but after a queen
H5 white needs to make some severe
concessions in order to prevent Queen H1
with a fast Checkmate available
Bishop C1 seals off the first Rank and
now it is finally time to make a
decisive breakthrough with Bishop A3
so of course Bishop takes A3 Queen H1
and queen G1 Checkmate is not an option
for white
so white ended up going for Rook E1
and uh now is a pretty funny position
where white is actually not capable of
moving any of these pieces
um so after Queen D5 the pin on The Rook
prevents Bishop takes A3 and the threat
of Rook A2 is pretty much decisive since
white would love to play rookie 2 to
stop it but in that case the bishop
drops
so in the game with just a couple of
seconds on his clock gory finally plays
Rook D1 and resigned after Rook A2
winning the White Queen
so uh yeah so I was really happy with
this game because I think it shows a
couple of key skills mostly in how to
improve your minor pieces and induce
Pawn weaknesses in your opponent's
position and both of these are really
key components to trying to win these uh
sort of equal or symmetrical positions
it's really important to do and even the
opening preparation back then is
extremely uh integral to winning this
game
Okay so
10 minutes left I'm not sure how much we
can do of the remaining games
um
okay I think we can
I think we can go really quickly through
this one since this is a really
important game so in this game I was
playing Black against Grand Master
Daniel neraditsky so in this game we're
going to be talking about how to play
for a win in the case when your opponent
also wishes to in the game so
Grandmaster now Daniel nerdski being
pirate rated than me natural has an
instinct to win against me and
especially given that this is the last
round of the 2022 US Open and the winner
would have a strong chance of going to
the U.S championship this was a very
important game for both of us so
previously we've looked at cases where a
weaker player is very intent on making a
draw with white in this case we're going
to be looking at a really Dynamic game
where there are plenty of chances for
both sides and some amazing tactics
along the way
so in this case uh I didn't really have
too much time to prepare but I decided
to just go for what I feel is the most
comfortable and so if you know that your
opponent is going to be trying to beat
you it's always very useful to just play
into what is most comfortable for you so
I go for the Sicilian con my favorite
opening of course so after A6
Bishop D3 so this is one of the more
trendy lines these days and after Bishop
C5 Knight B3 Bishop base seven
um yeah the opening moves are not really
that important so I'm not going to go
over them in too much detail but
essentially with Knight on C3 B5 is
generally strong to create some sort of
thread of B4 so after castles b494 D6
and E5 we've come to the end of my
preparation which is a half lie because
I definitely know more moves than this
but judging from the game you would find
that hard to believe given that my next
move is actually a gross blender that
loses the move in one game loses
who's the game in one move
so in this position black is actually
facing a lot of pressure along the D
file so the best move in this position
is move Knight D5 and the key is that
this move D6 allows an eventual Bishop
D7 trying to capture the Knight on the
other good move in this position for
black is D5 with a very similar idea
just trying to play Bishop D7 and
eventually pushing the a pawn with very
complicated position strong attack for
both sides
but in the game I decided to start with
the move Bishop D7 so I had mixed up my
preparation
so unfortunately after Bishop D7 I
realized a couple of things were wrong
so uh
I was thinking so the most obvious move
for white is the move he takes D6 after
which I intended Bishop takes E3 Queen
takes E3 and 95.
um
hoping to win the Knight on A4
um unfortunately there are like 50
problems with this line so after Bishop
D7 so the reason e takes D6 Bishop takes
A4 is not appropriate for black it's not
because of D takes E7 after which I
believe I'm relatively happy with these
State of Affairs but after the bishop G5
the pin on the E7 Knight is completely
decisive here so I cannot eliminate the
D6 Pawn an account of a discovered
attack
so after he takes D6 I'm forced to play
Bishop takes E3 check but unfortunately
neriditski actually did take on D6 in
the game when by flipping the move order
around with Bishop G5 white would pretty
much instantly win the game since Bishop
takes A4 he takes D6 would again lead to
that position where the pin is decisive
and it moved like D5 uh can lose in a
ton of different ways probably Knight
ac5 is the simplest and the best Queen
H5 is also very convincing since G6
Queen H6 is definitely not an option for
black and H6 Bishop takes H6 is quite
promising as well so definitely a close
call there but after he takes D6 I'm
very lucky to have this opportunity
which takes n95
although to judge it as winning for me
which I originally did is completely
false
so after Queen E4
um it's very tempting to play the move
F5 which would gain a Tempo on the queen
as well uh in addition to uh threatening
that on A4 but the truth is that uh I'm
not able to take an A4 because the E6
Pawn is hanging and with it goes the d59
so I'm forced to play the move G6 and
simply be down a pawn so this is a good
moment to stop and take stock of what
has happened so far in the game
so it's definitely a a non-ideal
situation so I'm playing against the
Grand Master who's rated above 2600 a
very strong player and uh very quickly
I've reached a situation where I'm down
a pawn
however in this position what I realized
was that my plan is actually fairly
obvious and White's plan is much less
soap so in this position I am down upon
but I have a lot of compensation in the
form of this a pawn run so after A5
will notice that the run of the a pawn
is going to be very annoying for white
essentially after A4 which gains a Tempo
on the night I want to play A3 and
soften up the queen side structure for
white
so I should probably play something like
Bishop C4 and meet A4 with Knight D4 but
um this is also fairly difficult to
understand so in the game white played
94 first which seems innocuous but after
the move Queen C8 turns out the Knight
on C5 is far from stable
so after
this move white is pretty much forced to
play Knight takes D7 Knight takes D7
um
pretty cool tactic results after Knight
takes E6 which is very tempting since F
takes E6 Queen takes E6 would pick up
the Knight on D5 and with it a bunch of
Pawns
and the in between move Knight 7 F6
which is desirable
allows white to throw in another
in-between move D7
and Knight takes f8 would end up hitting
the black queen
unfortunately for white black has the
move Knight five F6 available and so
after the queen moves white does have a
couple of Pawns in exchange for this
piece but the resulting position is not
good for white at all it's going to be
pretty much impossible to push that D6
pawn and black should be pretty much
winning here
so in the game neridisky opted for
Bishop B5 which is much stronger and
Knight F6 Queen E5 and A4 so I'm
continuing with my plan this position is
positionally quite acceptable for black
um so first of all there's the plan of
A3 which is pretty much impossible for
white to stop and secondly the knights
on D5 and F6 are doing a great job of
supporting each other
so in this position White's only way to
achieve a real Advantage would be with a
very bizarre move 9c6 so in the game I
had already dismissed this move fairly
quickly is after Queen B7 the B5 CSX
complex appears to be very weak but in
truth white has this amazing sequence
beginning with Rook takes D5 and Rook D1
so I'm not able to capture the bishop on
account of 97 check when my king is out
of squares so I would end up dropping my
queen
and so therefore I'm forced to let this
stay present and after Knight D4 this
position is pretty much losing for black
or losing as strong with the position is
pretty tough for black since white will
regain the exchange either on E8 or on
A8
although after A3 the position does
remain very complicated
so we have Rook D3 in the game which is
much more natural move just directed
against A3
so number C3
and now I have a chance to prevent white
from going for this Knight C6 move once
and for all with Rook A5 so the pressure
on the white Bishop is extremely painful
white doesn't really have any great
opportunities to move it away at this
point uh what white should probably do
is white probably needs to play the
bishop C6 but after A3 takes takes it's
very much unobvious to me that white has
a preferable position at all and that's
def white definitely does not
um black is the one with the attack and
the white pieces remain very fragile
here
so in the game after Rook A5 white
decided to go for A3 trying to simplify
the position but at this point with
black I no longer feel that I'm worse so
it is now my turn to complicate these to
introduce complications with Queen C5
and queen takes B4
so the immediate threat is simply A3
which would pretty much just expose the
white king completely and result in a
totally winning position
this position is already pretty much
winning for black not only is A3 being
threatened but Rook takes B5 with a
simple win of two pieces for a rook is
also very uh profitable for black so in
the game narrative decided to set a
pretty interesting trap with C4
so due to C4 vacating the C2 Square the
obvious move of A3 would actually lose
the game in a really sad way is after
Knight C2 there are no checks available
and I will drop one of my queen and Rook
but after C4 luckily the white King on
C1 is very weak and can be attacked in
another way and this is a this is a
moment where it's really important to
spend some time since this is definitely
a key position with many candidates for
black and indeed I've spent a lot of
time and was able to come up with the
best move here Rook takes B5
so in this position why does force to
take on B5 with the pawn as Knight takes
B5 Queen takes C4 is working way too
many pieces for this to be acceptable
for white after cb5 Queen C4 the central
Palm for white is that the king is
forced to hold on to the Rook with the
very awkward looking of King D2
and in another very bizarre twist the
White Queen is almost entirely out of
squares
so for example uh Queen E4 allows Knight
C5 with a double attack on the queen and
Rook uh Queen G3 Knight C5 is another
double attack with 94 check and Knight
takes D3
and we have like Queen E1 Knight C5 The
Rook is not able to escape as it needs
to hold on to the Knight on D4 so the
White Queen thing out of squares ends up
going to E2
and um Queen E2 Knight F4
we have another Fork here between the
queen and Rook Queen E3
and this is a moment where uh something
really clever you can do in your
practical games is to go for a
repetition just once to gain some time
on the clock since at this point I have
been down quite a lot of time as a
consequence of calculating these
sacrifices
so indeed I decided to repeat the
position once and at this point I think
my opponent would have been very happy
to make a draw but of course I'm not
going to do that so I decided to repeat
the position again with Knight takes G2
in this case I'm not particularly scared
of the queen F3 so after 95 Queen E4
this might have been a better
continuation for black but at the end of
the day I'm able to pick up that D6 pawn
and achieve a more or less winning
position
Queen two neither four
95.
Queen before check King C2 but
unfortunately here I faltered so in this
position I decided to play Knight F4 and
achieve a very similar position to the
one we just looked at picking up the D6
pawn and again this is pretty much
winning but it's very important when
you're playing someone as strong as
naroditski or just in general if you're
playing someone who also wants to win
the game then you do not give them any
chances to come back and indeed in this
position black is able to immediately
crack the defense with the move A3 it
looks a little bit strange but again The
Rook is not able to let go of the Knight
on D4
and pawn takes A3 Rook C8 is completely
non-acceptable the king is no longer
able to hide on B1
there are actually several moves here
that are better than what I played but
uh to make a long story short uh A3 is
the most decisive of them and yeah those
unfortunate situation so in the game
this ended up happening but again uh
black should still be winning here with
best play so uh
this position is actually quite tough in
order to win a game or anything like
this just because uh my piece are a
little bit Frozen here and the white
pawn and B5 ends up being quite strong
so 95 was played
so the double attack on The Rook at
Knight forces me to make a trade which
is not what I want to do and we're going
to see here well I know it is he is so
strong he is able to convert that
position where he was getting pretty
much checkmated immediately into a
position where uh we reach a rook end
game and um well they do say that all
Rook endings are drawn and indeed that
is how the game ended up sadly it would
take say four
so this position is already quite
difficult for black to handle I believe
the correct way for black to play
actually begins with king of fate and
then Rook H5 tried to pick up the H2
Pawn but why that's so important don't
expect me to be able to explain
um look at five
so Rook F5 is played because I don't
want white to play B4 and in this case I
would drop the F4 Pawn so Rick C4 is
forced he can fade B4 King E7
Hemi 3 King D6
so these moves are fairly natural and
you can see the other point of Rook F5
is that by putting pressure on F4 I'm
able to coerce white into letting me
create some connected pawns on the king
side
unfortunately I missed out on some
opportunities to go for some even more
amazing tactics for example in this
position it's already possible to start
with the insane move F4 sacrifice may be
Pawn to collect the B6 Pawn which should
result in a winning position for black
um
instead page six appears much more
natural just preparing G5 but here
narrative ski makes a very clever move
Rook F4
so not only is G5 prevented white is
actually threatening H5 himself which
would be extremely uncomfortable for me
as I do not want to ruin my Pawn
structure and go up the F5 Pawn
so in this position I had calculated the
move King C5 which appears very natural
after H5 takes takes takes unfortunately
I did not realize that this end game is
winning for black which it actually
happens to be with best play but very
abstract and white should be very happy
to reach such an end game given the
situation from before
so King C6 Rook C4 King D5 Rook F4 and
so obviously black can play King C5
again but I thought H5 seemed a little
bit more natural in the position
um just to prevent white from playing H5
and and I still have hopes with my fcon
not a move I'm terribly thrilled to play
but I didn't really feel that there is
another Choice available
and after Rook F1 the final chance to
win the game crops up with again the
beautiful move F4 this is Rook F4 King
C5 again wins the game for black
um unfortunately I played King E4 and
white ends up with a little bit too much
time is able to pick up the G6 spawn and
we made a drop so uh perhaps you might
be asking me why is it that I'm using a
game which I drew in the must win
lecture so first of all uh I probably
should have won this game
but of course that holds no weight in
the world of chess
um but I believe that what was important
here was the was the fighting spirit in
the middle game not willing to give up
once I realized that I had messed up and
um
and by creating a sort of counter play
on the white king in this position even
though I was down a pawn is able to
reach the situation where my opponent
obviously felt uncomfortable that's
another great advantage of going for a
sort of comfortable opening or Pawn
structure when you are in a must win
situation as you're likely to understand
it a little bit better than your
opponent and indeed the way the game
went I was able to outplay him from that
position despite the fact that he's
overall a much stronger player than me
and achieved a winning position which
should have been able to convert if I
was a little bit sharper that day
um okay
um so I think that's pretty good for
today we are a little bit over time but
more importantly I believe that the
material coverage date was of
substantial quality so um
all right so we're doing really well and
um yeah I think that's it for today
thank you so much for watching everybody
and Tim
so uh yeah I'll see you next time bye
time
[Music]
foreign